>> PLEASE STAY SAFE.
.
>> AND I JUST WANT TO WISH THE
BEST FOR EVERYONE.
THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE
HOMELESS NOW.
IT'S JUST VERY SAD AND
HEARTBREAKING.
.
>> IT TRULY IS.
>> MY HEART GOES OUT TO
EVERYBODY.
>> OURS AS WELL.
THANK YOU, ANDY.
STAND BY REAL QUICK.
WE'LL STAY ON TOP OF THE THE
STORM'S RECOVERY EFFORT.
>>> A BIG STORY OUT OF UKRAINE.
A PUTIN ALLY USING THE RUSSIAN
LEADER TO USE LOW-YIELD NUCLEAR
WEAPONS IN UKRAINE AFTER PUTIN
ILLEGALLY ANNEXED REFERENDUMS IN
THE REGION THAT THE WEST
DISMISSED AS SHAMS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID PUTIN'S
ACTIONS HAVE NO LEGITIMACY.
JOINING ME NOW TO TALK ABOUT
THIS IS THE GREAT GRANDDAUGHTER
OF SOVIET LEADER NIKITA CRUCIAL
CHEF.
SHE'S BEEN WITH US ON THIS
PROGRAM AS WELL.
NINA, THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
ONCE AGAIN, WE APPRECIATE IT.
WE TURN TO THE SITUATION IN
UKRAINE FROM THE DEVASTATION IN
FLORIDA.
PUTIN HAS CONCOCTED THIS
POLITICAL FANTASY WHEREBY
HOLDING THIS CEREMONY AND
DECLARING THE REGIONS AS 35R9 OF
RUSSIA.
HE WILL TALK ABOUT THE WAR BEING
A MATTER OF SELF-DEFENSE, I
SUPPOSE.
HE SAID HE WILL USE WHATEVER
WEAPONS HE HAS AT HIS DISPOSAL
TO DEFEND THE RUSSIAN STATE.
WILL THIS ESCALATE TO THE POINT
OF USING NUCLEAR WEAPONS?
.
>> WELL, THANK YOU, JIM.
I DON'T WANT TO SPECULATE ABOUT
THE NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
I THINK IF PUTIN HAS TOOLS, IF
HE NEEDS TO USE THEM, HE WILL
USE THEM.
THAT'S ALL I'M GOING TO SAY.
I'M SLIGHTLY HARDENED THAT THE
ALLY, THE CHECHEN FIGHTER SAID
PUTIN NEEDS TO USE THIS SMALL
TACTICAL WEAPONS.
BECAUSE NORMALLY WHAT WE
EXPERIENCE IN THE LAST SEVEN
MONTHS, IF HE SAYS SOMETHING IT
IS ACTUALLY NOT GOING TO BE
TRUE.
SO THAT GIVES ME A LITTLE BIT OF
HOPE.
YES, IT WAS A TREMENDOUS
PROPAGANDA SETUP YESTERDAY IN
THE KREMLIN.
AND IT WAS JUST POMP AND
CIRCUMSTANCE AND ALL THIS KIND
OF CRAZY RHETORIC AGAINST THE
WEST AND FOR THE RUSSIAN FUTURE
WHICH SUGGESTS THAT IF YOU'RE A
MAN AND WOMAN, THAT'S HOW YOU
NEED TO FIGHT THE WEST BECAUSE
YOU DON'T HAVE BINARY GENDERS.
THERE'S NO ECONOMIES BEING TAKEN
INTO CONSIDERATION, NO FUTURE OF
CONNECTIVITY.
I MEAN, IT WAS JUST
ABSOLUTELY -- I TEACH
PROPAGANDA, SO I KNOW MY
PROPAGANDA.
THAT WAS AN INCREDIBLY INSANE
SPEECH IN THIS REGARD.
BUT ALSO I LOOKED AT THE
AUDIENCE.
I LOOKED AT HIS ELITE
SUPPORTERS, AT THE GOVERNMENT.
AND THE GOVERNMENT LOOKED FROM
BORED TO DEVASTATED TO BARELY
WANTING TO BE THERE.
THERE WERE NO SMILES.
I GREW UP IN A POLITICAL FAMILY,
AS YOU MENTIONED.
I KNOW MY POLITICAL MEETINGS.
AND THAT WAS NOT A SUPPORTIVE
MEETING IN ANY WAY.
AND I DO FIND THIS DISCONNECT
ALSO QUITE INTERESTING AND
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO
CONTEMPLATE FOR THE FUTURE.
>> AND THIS ILLEGAL LAND GRAB
COMES AFTER SHAM REFERENDUMS
WERE HELD IN FOUR OCCUPIED AREAS
WHERE CITIZENS WERE FORCED TO
VOTE AT GUNPOINT, WHICH IS
UNBELIEVABLE WHEN YOU
CONTEMPLATE THAT.
HOW IS THAT EVEN VOTING?
WHAT HAVE YOU BEEN HEARING?
.
>> SAME THING.
IT'S EVEN WORSE THAN WHEN CRIMEA
REFERENDUM WAS HAPPENING IN
2014.
AT THE TIME IT WAS SORT OF A
PEACEFUL REFERENDUM, MORE
PEACEFUL.
AND CRIMEANS, MANY OF THEM, DID
WANT TO BE PART OF RUSSIA.
BUT I DON'T SEE -- I THINK THERE
ARE SOME RUSSIANS OR SOME
UKRAINIAN WITH RUSSIAN ORIGINS
THAT MAY WANT TO BE PART OF IT.
BUT AFTER WHAT WE HAVE SEEN, I
CAN'T IMAGINE PEOPLE REALLY
WANTING INCIDENT VOLUNTARILY.
BUT ONCE AGAIN, THE COUNTRY IS
IN THE GRASP OF PUTIN.
AND AFTER 22 YEARS, IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO PROTEST.
BUT IT IS -- I MEAN, THAT
YESTERDAY WAS JUST ANOTHER STEP
FOR ESCALATION.
AND TODAY I'VE BEEN TALKING --
YESTERDAY WE ALL TALKED.
AND TODAY I'M TALKING TO PEOPLE
IN MOSCOW IMIN MOSCOW TALKING TO
PEOPLE.
AND IT IS ABSOLUTE HOPELESSNESS
FOR WHAT THE FUTURE IS.
AND YOU HAVE SEEN PICTURES OF
PEOPLE FLEEING THIS PARTIAL
MOBILIZATION HE ANNOUNCED.
HE SAID WE NEED TO UNITE AND
DEFEND THE COUNTRY BECAUSE NOW
IT IS GOING TO BE AN ARGUMENT.
AND YET THE RUSSIANS DON'T WANT
TO DEFEND THIS BECAUSE THIS IS
CLEARLY PUTIN'S WAR.
AND VERY FEW OF THEM REALLY WANT
TO HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH IT.
>> YEAH.
I WAS GOING TO ASK YOU.
WE SAW INCREDIBLE IMAGES OF
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
RUSSIANS WAITING TO CROSS THE
BORDER, MANY FIGHTING AGE, MANY
FEARING THE POSSIBILITY OF BEING
DRAFTED TO FIGHT PUTIN'S WAR,
SOMETHING MANY DON'T WANT TO DO.
YOU ARE WORKING TO GET A YOUNG
MAN OUT OF THE COUNTRY.
CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THAT.
>> I WAS VERY LUCKY.
I DID GET HIM OUT OF THE
COUNTRY.
HE'S FINE.
BUT WHAT IS JUST A REMARKABLE,
ESPECIALLY YESTERDAY WITH THAT
POMP AND CIRCUMSTANCE, THE
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT THOSE
REPUBLICS ARE NOW HOME WITH
RUSSIA AND RUSSIANS ARE HAPPY
AND EXCITED AND THEY HAVE THIS
SHAM CELEBRATION ON THE RED
SQUARE AND ACTUALLY ANOTHER
RELATIVE OF MINE WAS DRIVING
AROUND MOSCOW TO SEE WHAT KIND
OF CELEBRATION IS ELSEWHERE, NOT
IN THE RED SQUARE.
AND SHE WAS TELLING ME THAT JUST
POLICE AND POLICE AND POLICE.
AND REALLY VERY FEW PEOPLE.
SO IT REALLY IS JUST TURNING
INTO THIS REMARKABLE DYSTOPIAN
NOVEL WE ARE LIVING IN.
THERE IS ONE RHETORIC.
AND THEN YOU COMPLETELY ABSOLUTE
DIVORCE FROM REALITY.
BUT, YES, THANK YOU.
MY NEPHEW IS FINE.
HE IS NOT SLEEPING ON TH